so you've been hearing all week from the
usual hysterical liars at the border
patrol somehow officers used a whip to
beat immigrants at the southern border
to searching for a better life trying to
get refugee status everything about that
is a complete lie
a lot of the haitians at our southern
border in del rio already had refugee
status in other countries that don't
offer free health care so they came here
by the way the border patrol doesn't
have whips they don't whip anybody they
ride horses and horses have rains
today the photographer who shot that
picture of the alleged whips were on the
record to confirm that the officers were
using reigns and they weren't whipping
anybody
so that should be the end of the story
but of course it suits the biden
ministration's political purposes which
is rushing as many new people into the
country as possible so they can win the
next several election cycles so they're
continuing to lie
the administration has banned the border
patrol from using horses
and today joe biden who has a fetish for
going after the week we notice
vowed to crush
the hourly workers who were involved in
this the border patrol officers watch
to see people treat it like they did
horses barely running over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences
there will be consequences it's an
embarrassment
can you imagine talking like that those
border patrol officers
didn't bring their own horses to beat
immigrants for fun they were riding
horses owned by joe biden's government
they were doing what they were told to
do which is enforce federal law passed
by the united states congress
and then the president of the united
states these are some of the weakest
people by the way in our country they're
just border patrol agents they have no
power
imagine being married to one of these
guys or being the child of one of these
guys and seeing the president united
states say we're going to crush these
people because they're evil and implying
they're racist
it's sick
so the dhs secretary and kamala harris
they both claimed the officers had used
whips
liars they said the nonexistent whips
prove that systemic racism is real
the investigation into what occurred has
not yet concluded
we know that those images painfully
conjured up the worst elements of our
nation's ongoing battle against systemic
racism and there needs to be consequence
and accountability
human beings should not be treated that
way and as we all know it also evoked
images of some of the worst moments of
our history
where that kind of behavior has been
used against
the indigenous people of our country has
been used against african americans
during times of slavery
this is someone who went to high school
and not even from here from canada
how did the best country in the world
get the worst people in the world to run
it it'd be interesting to know that
we can't control it at this point all we
can do is assess what they're doing hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else